le moindre signe de rebond épidémique
peut entraîner un durcissement des
mesures sur le territoire hellénique
alors que la grèce connaît depuis une
semaine une hausse du nombre de cas le
gouvernement a décidé de réagir
à partir de ce jeudi et jusqu'au 28
février
tous les commerces non essentiel ainsi
que les écoles fermeront leurs portes en
raison de nouvelles données j'assume la
responsabilité de la mise en place des
mesures supplémentaires pour la
protection de la santé publique
craignant une troisième vague de colis
de 19
les experts ont largement appuyé cette
décision le nombre de cas est passé à
1126 lundi contre 638 la veille la
moitié se trouvant à athènes et dans ses
environs
dans la capitale on estime à 71 % le
nombre de lits dans les services
d'urgences occupés par des malades
ducobu de 19 contre 62 pour cent la
semaine dernière
ces mesures renforcées on accompagne
d'autres déjà en vigueur dont un
couvre-feu et la validation par sms des
autorités afin de sortir et décision qui
inquiète la population sur le plan
économique les choses deviendront
vraiment difficile lorsque la situation
du coc vie 19 sera terminé ensuite nous
devrons faire face à de vrais problèmes
des problèmes économiques
je pense que si nous nous en tenons aux
mesures elles souvent un impact positif
mais pour l'économie tout cela est
vraiment de mauvais augure l'économie
est effectivement au coeur des débats
très fortement pâte et par l'absence de
touristes en raison de la pandémie
le pays est à la recherche d'un deuxième
souffle pour ses finances lundi dernier
la grèce a conclu avec israël en accord
touristique permettant aux citoyens
d'actionner de voyager entre les deux
pays
de quoi permettre aux voyageurs de
profiter entre autres des côtes du pays
et des richesses de sa capitale mais
avec l'approbation des autorités